[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires voici les titres de
l'actualité
tout d'abord la france est confiné les
petits commerces sont fermés des mères
on nous fait un combat pendant que les
commerçants eux cherchent des solutions
pour écouler les stocks nous verrons
lesquels l'hommage des écoles de france
l'hommage de la nation au professeur
samuel pâtit une minute de silence et
des débats sur la liberté d'expression
ont rythmé cette rentrée scolaire pas
comme les autres le tour de france
cycliste 2021 été dévoilée cette semaine
la course la plus populaire du monde
réserve encore vous allez voir quelques
belles surprises notamment dans les
alpes
enfin des enfants d'un petit club de
foot du mans ont eu la chance
d'accueillir vous allez le voir en fin
de journal le real madrid voilà comme je
vous le disais dans les titres nous
commençons ce vent jt des territoires
par l'hommage national qui a été rendu à
samuel pâtit ce prof d'histoire géo de
conflans sainte honorine victime d'un
horrible attentat dans toutes les écoles
de france une minute de silence a été
respectée à 11 heures précises
vous voyez ici sur ces images de nos
confrères des télévisions locales de
france
les hommages nationaux qui ont eu lieu à
annecy à rennes à saint dié dans les
vosges ou encore dans la ville de troyes
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions d'élèves
après cette cérémonie et regardez ça
tous les domaines scolaire donc si bien
donc parler
de faire comme si de rien n'était pas ce
que c'est important sur une heure de
cours sur toute la vie bat en hommage à
quelqu'un qui a perdu sa vie' on voit ce
qui s'est passé un peu pour se comparer
aux fidji puis on en parle à l'école ça
fait réfléchir sur ce qui s'est passé
était violent quoi d'apprendre ça c'est
pas quelque chose qui est qu'ils
arrivent tous les jours etc c'est assez
choquant est ce qui est ce qui lui est
arrivé est basse et faut plus que ça se
reproduise parce que c'est pas faux
c'est anormal
cette rentrée s'est donc faite dans un
climat difficile pour les élèves
entre hommage national et nouveau
protocole sanitaire à respecter caroline
fichter de la chaîne wéo s'est rendu
dans une classe a calé dans les hauts de
france pour y rencontrer des lycéens
regardez ce reportage
il est midi les élèves du lycée léonard
de vinci sorte de cour
ici le port du masque est généralisé la
distanciation globalement respectée par
contre dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement qui accueille plus de
1000 jeunes la situation est différente
bas pour l'instant j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya pas grand chose qui a changé du
coup ils sont pas trop préoccuper de ça
ça m'inquiète parce que enfin
emmanuel macron a dit que c'était pour
protéger protéger les jeunes mais a pas
vraiment quoi les élèves sur tous les a
sur les autres balles et distanciation
sont pas respectées non plus
on est tous regroupés à sur lot donc ça
a peu compliqué côté enseignants le
discours est sensiblement le même il
faut accentuer la distanciation et pour
ça il faudrait travailler en demi groupe
c'est ce que demande le syndicat snes
fsu pour pouvoir poursuivre l'accueil
des élèves dans de bonnes conditions au
sein des établissements
toutes les revendications qu'on a tous
les mouvements de grève qui ont lieu des
enseignants ce moment c'est vraiment
pour garantir le meilleur accueil
possible aux élèves pour protéger les
élèves et leurs familles pour permettre
d'accueillir des élèves c'est la
solution dès 2000 groupe donc la bagarre
qu'on mène c'est vraiment pour laisser
les établissements ouverts accueillir
faire court parce qu'on sait bien que le
distant ciel c'est une catastrophe pour
les élèves donc voilà c'est vraiment
cette idée d'accueillir en toute
sécurité pour les personnels les élèves
et leurs familles
le snes fsu a déposé un préavis de grève
pour toute la semaine prochaine objectif
dénoncer collectivement l'insuffisance
du protocole sanitaire l'atteinte à la
santé et la sécurité au travail des
personnels et des conditions de travail
dégradées les ehpad sont durement
touchées par cette pandémie vous le
savez les personnes âgées font partie
des très nombreuses victimes
le gouvernement de son côté souhaite
tester plus vite plus rapidement grâce à
de nouveaux outils
c'est le cas de ces tests dits
antigénique que l'on peut trouver dans
les pharmacies depuis quelques jours les
équipes de canal 32 sont allés dans un
établissement de b viande dans l'aube
pour tenter d'y voir plus clair regarder
depuis ce mardi matin et durant quatre
jours dans cet état de bréviandes tous
les personnels passent un test
antigénique un test extrêmement rapide
on n'attend pas une à deux journées dans
les laboratoires
ces fioles moi je viens davis et le bot
du tube à essai j'ai des pauses 5
gouttes et ensuite une fois que les
trois sont réalisés je lance le compte à
rebours pour 15 minutes
une seule barre ça veut dire que le test
est négatif et quand il y a deux bars ça
veut dire que le test est positif nous
avons 100 % de test négatif plus de 40
minutes est un des génies qui ont été
distribués auprès des 44 ehpad de l'aube
bas ces établissements accueillant des
personnes vulnérables
c'est est massif ont pour vocation de
protéger les personnels les résidents et
surtout stopper la propagation du virus
est assez lourd quand même
psychologiquement parce qu'on se dit que
si la personnes non résidentes ont
malade ça peut être à cause de nous
quand on a un peu enrhumé ou quand on a
un peu des mots tête un peu mal à la
gorge
oui on peut se poser des questions et
bah là on se pose plus de questions faut
bien comprendre que le personnel qui
travaille en ehpad est un personnel qui
vient le matin souvent avec la trouille
ils ont peur peur d'attraper ce virus
c'est la même problématique au centre
hospitalier ou dans les cliniques et
donc le fait de voir ce test sont des
cas négatifs et donc on va pouvoir
redémarrer à zéro faire du bon travail
en cas de résultat positif les
personnels doivent s'isoler durant sept
jours
ce dépistage auprès d'environ 2500
salariés doit également permettre de
dresser un état des lieux
et puis le mois de mars les
professionnels sont très attentives à
cela elles nous disent faire très
attention quand elles vont faire les
courses quand elles font en sorte sur
leur vie privée ils savent aller
rassurer dans leurs gestes du quotidien
donc oui effectivement c'est un test à
l'instant t et dans 15 ans en trois
jours c'est peut être ça peu différent
chaque professionnel qui se serait senti
en difficulté dans sa vie privée qui
estiment avoir été mis en difficulté
pourra venir nous voir et on pourra lui
faire un test rapidement et dans le
quart d'heure qui suivant le résultat et
pourra travailler sereinement la rs par
le biais de la protection civile a
également distribué 7 est un petit génie
qu auprès des quatre unités de soins
longue durée
je vous en parlais dans les titres en
début de journal direction la loi
maintenant pendant que les maires monte
au créneau contre le gouvernement
certains commerçants cherchent des
solutions pour continuer leur activité
et ne pas sombrer surtout vous allez le
voir il ya ceux qui contournent le
problème en se réinventant avec la mise
en place de sessions shopping
ça s'appelle comme ça et sur les réseaux
sociaux d'autres trouvent des failles au
système pour continuer d'ouvrir leur
boutique c'est un reportage réalisé par
les équipes de tl7 dans la loire
regardez cette boutique est fermée
depuis vendredi mais pourtant à
l'intérieur la propriétaire s'activent
leur confinement a été un coup de massue
mais la commerçante a choisi de ne pas
se laisser abattre et de proposer ses
services de manière différente chaque
mardi soir elle proposera un live sur sa
page facebook il suffit d'un ordinateur
d'un téléphone et de lettres de sa fille
comme mannequin et le tour est joué
le premier live a été un vrai succès 35
commandes en une demi heure
les clientes étaient au rendez vous
c'est tout simple un ordinateur vous
mettez des numéros en fait pour vous
comment dire pourquoi vous perdre dans
vos achats et en fait les gens donne le
numéro de l'article
avec leur taille il n'y a rien de
compliqué tout le monde peut le faire
vraiment vraiment les commandes seront
ensuite livrés ou proposer en drive
devant la boutique
la question ici de rentrer dans le
commerce à saint-just-saint-rambert ce
concept store a choisi de rester ouverts
une fronde pour dénoncer les décisions
jugée incohérente du gouvernement la
boutique est restée ouverte cette fin de
semaine et ce matin les commerçants
jouent sur les failles du système
pour continuer les ventes que donc on a
décidé de
d'ouvrir temps que les grandes surfaces
pour et vente de tout temps que babu
gifi noz la foir'fouille et
reste très ouvert parce que ils vendent
pour certains ils se cachent derrière le
papier toilette pour d'autres c'est le
gel hydro alcoolique c'est bien connu on
va tous acheté d'un peuple et que chez
gifi
mais ce rayon première nécessité n'est
pas vraiment là à des fins économiques
chacun est libre de se servir
gratuitement le cadeau de la maison de
ces commerçants qui cache une vraie
colère mais en fait c'est moi qui suis
confiné
parce que ma gamine elle va à l'école
enfin mes gamins ils vont à l'école
les gens qui bossent bas ils vont au
boulot
donc il reste confiné en fait les
personnes âgées les chômeurs et les
petits commerçants
c'est quoi ce confinement en carton qua
non mais faites-moi vrai confie noir
dans ces cas là le premier il accepte
quoi mais un vrai confinement mais la
regagner
regardez ça c'est la vie ces commerçants
ne savent pas combien de temps leur
fronde va durer ceux qui souhaitent
alerter la population et pouvoir ré
ouvrir le plus rapidement possible pour
assurer la période la plus importante de
l'année pour leur chiffre d'affaires les
fêtes de fin d'année les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie de leur côté
tentent de se mobiliser pour aider les
commerçants en difficulté en bretagne
vous allez le voir la cci propose de
mettre en place des solutions comme
celle du click and collect en fait le
retrait en magasin qui permettra à ces
commerçants de continuer une activité
malgré la fermeture administrative c'est
un reportage de tva la chaîne de rennes
regardez boutique rond c'est une
institution dans le quartier de paramé à
saint malo si ce magasin de vêtements
multimarques a ouvert ses portes en 1947
ce n'est qu'au printemps dernier qu'il a
lancé son premier site internet de vente
en ligne
c'est vrai qu'en tant que président des
commerçants j'incite mes collègues à
faire de même déjà fonctionner sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook instagram
ils sont une des petites boutiques ils
peuvent mettre des produits de fûts et
des sites gratuits aussi pour les
petites secondes et petites structures
voilà des constructeurs chinois il ya
d'autres dans le secteur qui en ont et
qui ont fait pareil
7digital isation représente un travail
considérable de référencement pour les
commerçants mais devrait à terme porter
ses fruits
si une nouvelle clientèle à capter voilà
et je me mettrai le temps qu'il faut
mais méfiez confiante la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie considère aussi
qu'internet est la deuxième vitrines des
commerçants
elle renforce en ce moment c'est action
dead et d'accompagnement les dix
conseillers de la chambre de commerce
vont appeler les entreprises pour les
aider d'ordonner des solutions cas soit
sur des produits de base ou des produits
plus complexes
c'est ainsi que le bar hôtel restaurant
le britannique s'est lancé dans la vente
à emporter en mai dernier
alors on s'est dit qu'en reprenant là un
petit peu de ventes emporté chose qu'on
avait jamais fait puisque ce n'était pas
notre boulot on a attenté commence à
payer quelques factures
à l'heure actuelle je ne sais pas
suffisant pour sauver les meubles
faute de rentabilité cette vente à
emporter surtout vu comme un moyen de ne
pas perdre le contact avec les
clientèles des habitués nous prenons
maintenant la direction des yvelines
avec le nouveau confinement les
entreprises doivent s'adapter et avoir
recours majoritairement vous le savez au
télétravail c'est le cas pour les
sociétés du secteur tertiaire
exemple avec deux entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines et le technocentre
renault de guyancourt
avec ses onze mille salariés un
reportage de nicolas landry pour tv 78
elles sont nombreuses à pouvoir
poursuivre leurs activités en
télétravail les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines majoritairement dans
le secteur tertiaire ont remis en place
cette organisation spécialisée dans les
services de stockage informatique et de
cyber sécurité
antemeta décidé de mettre 110 personnes
en télétravail sur les 180 employés du
site de guyancourt
on a pris la décision avec l'ensemble
des membres du comité de direction de
généraliser le télétravail en assurant
une permanence pour les activités qui
d'être continuer notamment nos activités
de surf de monitoring commercial et
d'intervention et de maintenance chez
nos clients
je pense que dans tous les cas le
télétravail en tout cas le confinement
change les méthodes de travail pour
l'avenir et que le télétravail va
forcément devenir une petite barbe en
tout cas pour les entreprises et nous on
constate déjà même dans nos entretiens
de recrutement qui effectivement l'école
les candidats nous pose la question
autre exemple avec d link france son
siège est installé dans le quartier de
l'hyper centre de montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui sur la vingtaine de
collaborateurs 17 poursuivre leurs
activités depuis leur domicile
il reste malgré tout des besoins de 30
ans de d'être au pureau on n'est pas
dans le même compliment que le premier
confinement le premier confinement
l'activité s'était réduite de façon
assez importante
là c'est pas le cas pour l'instant donc
vallée besoin d'être bureau parfois
périlleux du côté du technocentre
renault le télétravail est aussi la
règle seulement 10% des onze mille
salariés sont actuellement présents sur
le site
leur présence est nécessaire de par leur
mission l'activité sur des prototypes
sur des bancs d'essai ou les projets
urgents sur de futurs véhicules
avant ce nouveau confinement depuis le 7
septembre 2020 les collaborateurs du
technocentre télétravail et trois ou
quatre jours par semaine
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
le nouveau tracé du tour de france
cycliste a été dévoilée cette semaine le
tour de france 2021 est la course la
plus populaire du monde vous le savez
elle réserve pourtant encore une fois
quelques belles surprises notamment dans
les alpes c'est ce qu'ont voulu savoir
nos confrères de 8 mont blanc regardez
ce reportage
trois jours après le premier grand
rendez vous du tour de france 2021 et un
contre-la-montre la huitième étape du 3
juillet prochain entre oyonnax et le
grand bornand promet déjà beaucoup
151 km avec trois difficultés au
programme la côte de mons actionner le
col de romme et le col de la colombière
avant de redescendre sur la station des
aravis il y a deux ans julian
alaphilippe s'était imposé en patron sur
ligne droite finale devant le stade de
biathlon sylvie becaert
on a la chance de par notre situation
géographique au grand bornand de se
trouver soi l'entrée des alpes soit la
sortie des alpes et là en l'occurrence
on sera avec l'étape pau oyonnax le
grand bornand à l'entrée des alpes et ce
sera la première épreuve de vérité par
rapport aux grimpeurs
pour connaître leur état de forme en
tout cas c'est une épreuve qui est
attendu et quelques semaines après
l'annulation de la coupe du monde de
biathlon
prévue initialement décembre ce retour
du tour de france au grand bornand est
perçu comme une vraie reconnaissance
c'est vraiment un grand grand honneur
une grande fierté de recevoir à nouveau
les coureurs de la grande boucle
c'est la huitième fois que le grand
bornand et ville étape du tour de france
c'est en tout cas reconnaître la culture
vélo grand bornand le grand bornand est
labellisé vélo accueil vélo c'est aussi
reconnaître quelque part notre savoir
faire
le lendemain de cette arrivée au grand
bornand le peloton et la caravane
partiront du cuse pour rallier tignes
pour l'étape reine des alpes et ses cinq
difficultés
un passage du tour de france que la
commune de la vallée de l'arve affiche
fièrement depuis ce lundi après 18 ans
d'absence
ça fait cinq ans qu'on préparait un
dossier on a on a montré qu'on était
capable d'organiser des courses
cyclistes comme d'autres événements
durant ces dernières années
le hasard a fait qu'on a rencontré
christian prudhomme de passage en train
de manger un sandwich sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville il ya trois ans et on a
commencé à discuter sérieusement et puis
voilà trois ans après on a ce tour
cluzet le cyclisme c'est une histoire
qui dure dans un passé plus récent le
tour ça va mont-blanc il a fait
plusieurs fois escale en ce qui concerne
la grande boucle
ce sera la troisième année après 1994 et
2002 le départ s'est vraiment partager
quelque chose de plus long sur une
matinée avec la population c'est
vraiment pour la population que nous
avions opté pour un départ
alors on a la chance d'avoir quand même
un week-end complet parce que le la
veille le 3 juillet le tour passera dans
nos montagnes
donc ça sera vraiment encore une fois
une fête à la fois pour voir passer les
coureurs et pour partager avec eux le
moment de préparation du matin dans une
période plus que compliquée à gérer pour
les collectivités l'annnonce du parcours
du tour de france 2021 est une véritable
bouffée d'oxygène en espérant que cette
prochaine édition puisse soutenir aux
dates prévues
voilà je vous dis dans les titres juste
avant le confinement des enfants d'un
petit club de foot du mans l'aes
villaret ont eu la chance d'accueillir
le real madrid
il s'agit de la fondation real madrid
clinique c'est une branche du célèbre
club espagnol qui organise des stages
dans toute l'europe pour récolter de
l'argent à des fins caritatives
au terme de cette semaine d'entraînement
quatre jeunes sarthois et est même
sélectionné pour un stage national
regardez ce reportage de lmtv sartre sur
place
à la toussaint le mans viard est
accueilli la fundación real madrid
clinics une branche du célèbre club de
football espagnol qui organise des
stages à travers l'europe pour soutenir
des oeuvres caritatives en afrique et en
amérique centrale et du sud
au terme de la semaine quatre
footballeurs été choisi pour participer
à un stage national
une sélection basée sur les performances
sportives mais surtout sur le
comportement et l'état d'esprit des
jeunes s'est parlé de valeurs c'est
inculquer les valeurs du real de madrid
c'est à dire la rigueur le le travail le
surpassement de soi l'éthique sportive
on essaye de l'inculquer va aux enfants
toute la semaine
et puis surtout le fair play et puis le
savoir vivre ensemble
au programme tournoi et entraînement les
enfants ont découvert des méthodes et du
matériel spécifique à la cantera le
centre de formation du real madrid
on a rapporté la sporty shon donc d'un
nouvelle technologie qui permet de
calculer la vitesse
des enfants sur du dribbling l'ass
football qui permet de calculer la
vitesse de frappe et la rotation du
ballon
sur la frappe de chaque enfant
deschaseaux lumineux qui change de tout
leur permet aux enfants de prise
d'informations assez assez rapide
voilà dans le sens du jeu les
partenaires qui changent voilà pas mal
de choses en tout cas je pense que ça
séduit les enfants une opportunité
d'apprentissage pour les 90 participants
et une occasion d'ouverture pour le club
un vrai moment de partage et des changes
puisque enfin quand on vit avec d'autres
pays et d'autres process et je pense que
c'est aussi ça qui est intéressant c'est
de voir notre façon de procéder
ils nous ont fait découvrir des choses
moi je pense que j'ai sur une semaine
c'est toujours agréable de s'ouvrir
ça permet vraiment de de montrer que
nous on est capable d'acquérir aussi
c'est ces moments de découverte va de
d'autres vision du football
vendredi soir les quatre heureux élus
sont nommés mais surprise
l'un d'eux est directement qualifié pour
la finale européenne qui aura lieu à
madrid en fin de saison
direction maintenant gérardmer dans les
vosges pour une tradition qui ne pourra
pas être respecté
en effet pour la première fois depuis
2014 le gérômois alain simoneau ne
pourra pas jouer le père noël en chine
lui qui pourtant est adulé pendant trois
semaines sur place au moment des fêtes
ne pourra pas faire vibrer la magie du
père noël là bas le confinement et
surtout la perspective de respecter
trois semaines de quarantaine l'ont
complètement découragé mais c'est un mal
pour un bien car il pourra passer les
fêtes de fin d'année en famille
regardez ce reportage des équipes
devient vosges qui l'ont rencontré ne
vous y trompez pas c'est bien mon habit
de travail quelle ainsi mona nous a
ouvert ses portes ce mercredi à
gérardmer depuis 2014 chaque hiver ce
vosgien se rend en chine dans la
province du sichuan à chengdu une petite
ville de 14 millions d'habitants où
durant les fêtes de fin d'année il joue
au père noël pour le plus grand plaisir
des clients d'un gigantesque complexe
hôtelier
mais cette fois point de santa claus
dans l' empire du milieu
la perspective de trois semaines de
quarantaine là-bas et le confinement qui
vient de se rajouter ont eu raison de
son voyage mais à quelque chose malheur
est bon pour cet ancien bûcheron
autant j'avais un sourire et chats
ordinaire quand je suis parti la
première année à pékin
autant maintenant j'ai la larme à l'oeil
a même une gauche là où chaque fois je
m'en vais quoi finalement
généralement je vais me retrouver avec
mes enfants et mes petits enfants pour
la période de noël
à condition que l'on puisse se réunir
apparemment on va falloir attendre un
petit peu et puis le travail dans les
vosges ne manquent pas à alain simoneau
possède quatre gîtes de dans la perle
des vosges de au grand valtin avec
quelques travaux à faire et ce ne sont
malheureusement pas les locataires qui
vont le gênait martray c'est magique est
en ce moment même bien j'ai quand même
un petit peu fébrile et pour la neuvième
fois
m -a dans l'année moi j'aimais touristes
qui viennent de partir le méritez tous
les moutons magie de vienne se vider et
les commet un en avant pour une bonne
semaine à travailler là ne les aurais
pas elle à la visibilité
la cellule pour le moins venir quoi les
temps sont durs y compris pour le père
noël qui espère bien que ses gîtes se
rempliront pour les fêtes de fin d'année
allez faisons un voeu direction
l'occitanie à présent qui a décidé de
mettre un peu d'eau dans son vin
c'est une expression qui prend tout son
sens vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage
car pendant neuf mois plus de 300
bouteilles de vin vont être immergées
dans les parcs à huîtres de l'étang de
leucate
une manière originale de conserver et de
faire évoluer surtout ses cuvées toutes
les explications avec nos confrères de
wierre occitanie sur place c'est une
cuve est un peu particulière
ces bouteilles de vin vont être
immergées souvent on va amener les
bouteilles sur l'étal sur les parcs à
huîtres
c'est donc dans l'étang de leucate que
ces viticulteurs vont plonger une partie
de leur production sous les parcs à
huîtres
une grande première pour ce vigneron on
sait très bien que sur les vins rouges
l'altitude permet de très bonne
conservation et de très bon élevage
pourquoi ne pas essayer en les
maintenant dans la même température et
même luminosité d'avoir des résultats et
d'analyser ce que ça peu ce que ça peut
apporter sur des vins de garde
laurent lui n'en est pas à son premier
coup d'essai puisque cela fait dix ans
qu'il immerge chaque année ces
bouteilles de vin blanc la pression qui
va être exercée sur le bouchon amène au
niveau 2 du vin et cherche des yeux qui
est différent on pourra dire que le vin
va gagner en volume le vélv a gagné
aussi sur des notes iodées mais qui sont
déjà présentes sur ce également être
renforcée le simple fait d'évoluer c'est
pas de l'eau de mer qui va passer un
d'aller goûter ce sont six changements
de pression atmosphérique qui amène une
évolution différente et ce sont donc que
348 bouteilles sur les cinquante mille
produite qui vont rester accroché à ce
parc ostréicole carvin et huîtres font
plutôt bon ménage
la chanson une très bonne qualité d'eau
c'est une lacune qui est au bord de la
méditerranée entourée de montagnes les
corbières les pyrénées on met
les verts à côté des huîtres elles
grandissent ensemble et on lui en plus
sont mis à les déguster
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à attendre
neuf mois avant de pouvoir les sortir de
l'étang ce qui n'empêche pas de goûter
déjà les cuvées précédentes il n'y a pas
de creux un bouche à la longueur à
consommer avec modération bien sûr
voilà place à la rubrique et
coentreprises et région avec vous me
faites picot bonjour et merci d'être
présent dans le grand jt des territoires
dans cette crise sanitaire en plein
confinement certains jeunes n'hésitent
pas pourtant à se lancer dans l'aventuré
entrepreneuriale c'est le cas de ce
jeune couple dont vous allez nous parler
basé près d'annecy qui lance une
nouvelle gamme de biscuits en forme de
billes
bonjour série louis la marque s'appelle
le pape et pis ce jeune couple a créé
d'ailleurs deux personnages qui font la
marque et ses deux personnages c'est eux
c'est madame et monsieur madame épi li
de son vrai nom fatiha et pilliard abed
son mari qui est pape
ça c'est pour l'histoire mais ensuite il
ya les biscuits salés sucrés qui sont
directement inspirés des saveurs que le
jeune couple a pu découvrir lors de
différents voyages un concept est fort
les biscuits en forme de billes sont
uniques au monde la grande distribution
s'est intéressée à eux mais il a fallu
fabriquer plus
eh bien figurez vous qu'ils ont vendu
leur maison pour créer leur usine
et pour la petite histoire sachez que
les deux tourtereaux sont encore
infirmier de profession ils sont souvent
appelés en renfort
abed est tombé malade mais cela ne les a
pas empêchés de poursuivre leurs rêves
leurs envies d'aller jusqu'au bout et
ils recherchent toujours des
investisseurs pour passer à la vitesse
supérieure et créer des emplois
merci michel picaud et à très vite nous
allons dans l'aube maintenant pour une
drôle de dégustation vous allez le voir
une boulangerie de la commune de sainte
savine met à votre disposition là bas
des rouleaux de papier toilette à
déguster un clin d'oeil humoristique en
cette période de confinement le but est
bien c'est amuser ses clients et ça
marche comme le montre ce reportage nos
confrères de canal 32 sur place regardez
je suis avec mon nous voyez que c'est
parti d'un nouveau délit on sait
vraiment
on va les faire on verra bien je n'ai
pas vu qu'on avait fait dans le coin
chez bon allez c'est parti il faut bien
qu'un lien qu'ils fassent qu'on
attendait nous c'est de voir des gens
sourire à rigoler c'est ce qu'on voulait
vraiment parce que le truc c'est de
bonne humeur et c'est de se faire se
fendre la porte un nom dit quoi c'est
plus un le fait de dire d'avoir les
petits commerces sont là on est on est
très bien capable de faire loire aussi
qu'on est vivant que je pense tous les
collègues restaurateurs qui ne peuvent
pas s'amuser donc on fait ça pour eux
aussi pour savoir que nous aussi on peut
bouger là où on est assez on rigole
c'est qu'on a des commandes
donc voilà il ya des gens qui veulent
faire leurs gâteaux d'anniversaire comme
ça oui que mon mode rush trouve ça
humour et si je fais je pense qu'on est
dans une année de merde comme on dit
mais voilà le papier le papier toilette
fait fait bon usage
voilà merci de votre fidélité merci
d'avoir suivi le grand jt des
territoires sur nos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde et rendez
vous dans une prochaine édition
au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]